[Música]
miren si la estadística no nos falla el
100 por ciento de las mujeres que están
aquí conoce al menos un anticonceptivo 7
de 10 de ustedes son usuarias de alguno
tal vez sus amigos sus maestros su
familia sus médicos se lo recomendaron
les dijeron que era bueno su uso incluso
que hasta era responsable
pero hay un poquito de información que
tal vez no les dieron
seis de estas siete mujeres están en
riesgo de tener cáncer cervicouterino
invasor cáncer de mama y de que se forme
un coágulo en su sangre y pueda matarlas
déjenme ponerlos en perspectiva
cáncer y eventos cardiovasculares son
las dos principales causas de muerte en
el mundo en mujeres y también en nuestro
país
tan sólo este año morirán 15.000 mujeres
a causa de estos cánceres en mexico y
ese es sólo la primera causa de muerte
la segunda eventos cardiovasculares 17
millones y medio de personas se mueren
al año en el mundo por esto una de cada
tres personas que se muere tiene que ver
con eventos cardiovasculares y si usas
anticonceptivos hormonales aumenta su
riesgo hasta seis veces de presentar uno
de estos
y eso sin contar quistes migrañas
cambios en el estado de ánimo cambios en
el peso
y las preguntas obligadas entonces son
usamos medicamentos que nos enferman y
pueden matarnos y es que acaso no hay
otra solución
si hay otra opción y de esa vamos a
hablar
y en realidad usamos estos medicamentos
porque los sistemas nacionales de salud
se han preocupado más por solucionar
problemas que por atender pacientes
y es así que la anticoncepción y el
control de la natalidad se han
convertido en una prioridad a nivel
mundial y nacional sobre todo en países
como el nuestro donde hay mucha pobreza
miren déjenme contarles una historia muy
interesante porque conocer la historia
nos permite recordar o entender por qué
estamos aquí parados hoy nuestra
historia empieza en 1800 con un político
económico inglés que se llamó maltos
malthus propuso la idea de que los
recursos y las poblaciones crecían a
velocidades diferentes de tal manera que
si no detenemos el crecimiento de la
población
pronto se acabarían los recursos a él se
le ocurrieron dos estrategias para
evitar que los pobres se acabarán su
comida 1 hacer que nazcan menos pobres y
2 lograr que los individuos indeseados
se vayan muriendo poco a poco
posterior a malthus se privilegiaría
sobre todo la estrategia de que nazcan
menos pobres de hecho hasta nuestros
días seguimos pensando que un bebé o un
embarazo es algo de lo que nos
deberíamos de cuidar
y en este set llegaría a mediados de
1940 saunier quien fuera la creadora y
artífice de los anticonceptivos como los
conocemos hoy ella fue una luchadora
incansable por los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de las mujeres pero
tampoco tenía mucho aprecio por las
clases menos favorecidas
ella comprendía el control de la
natalidad como la oportunidad para darle
más hijos a los más capacitados y menos
hijos a los menos capacitados llamando a
las clases trabajadoras imbéciles
benignos y maleza humana
esta idea siguió preocupando mucho a los
países y lo empezaron a llevar a las
reuniones internacionales e incluso
empezó a ver reuniones internacionales y
de la onu exclusivamente con esta
ideología que hacemos para que no se nos
acaben los recursos
la primera exclusivamente para esto fue
en 1974 en bucarest vendrían varias y
una muy importante 1994 en el cairo si
me lo preguntan ahí vino la confusión en
1994 en el cairo se reconoció por
primera vez el derecho a decidir el
número de hijos que quieres tener y el
espacio entre ellos así como el acceso a
los anticonceptivos como dos derechos
humanos básicos fundamentales de las
mujeres y eso merece un aplauso
pero ahí se confundió de manera muy
sutil la necesidad de consumir
anticonceptivos como si éstos fueran la
única opción para lograr esta libertad
en las mujeres y en medicina así pasa
cuando la que tienes es la única opción
para dar el tratamiento para una
enfermedad entonces cualquier efecto
secundario puede ser tolerado en aras de
poder recibir el tratamiento y así es
que terminamos el día de hoy después de
una larga historia pensando que los
anticonceptivos son la única opción para
la planificación familiar para la
prevención del embarazo en adolescentes
para la disminución del aborto
actualmente cualquier motivo es bueno
para para meter a una mujer en
anticoncepción sangras mucho sangras
poco te duele tienes quistes miomas
endometriosis adenomiosis bueno acné
toma anticonceptivos
en un congreso reciente internacional se
propuso la estrategia de distribuir
masivamente los anticonceptivos como el
plan para prevenir la pobreza
el calentamiento global y hasta el
terrorismo
y a mí esa idea como que no me
no me sabía muy bien
miren desde que yo empecé a estudiar
medicina una de las cosas que me dijeron
con mucha claridad era que nuestro país
había mucha pobreza y que una manera una
estrategia para disminuir la pobreza era
lograr por el medio que fuera que
hubiera menos pobres
de tal forma que en mis guardias durante
el internado una de mis funciones
principales era la de convencer a más
mujeres de que firmaran por un
anticonceptivo no sé si lo saben pero en
nuestro país existe la meta plasmada en
el plan específico de acción de
anticoncepción de que el 70 por ciento
de las mujeres que ingresan a un
hospital a tener un bebé tiene que salir
o esterilizada o con un anticonceptivo
de larga duración tres de nuestras
principales instituciones entre las que
destaca el link logran este objetivo en
el link el 83 por ciento de las mujeres
firman por uno de estos métodos ni qué
decir cuando hice mi servicio social
rural ahí por primera vez daba consulta
a uno a uno como médico en formación y
recibí en persona las quejas de muchas
mujeres que me decían aquí me siento mal
no me caen bien subí de peso tengo
alteraciones en el estado de ánimo me
duele la cabeza tengo migrañas
yo tenía que decirles que no era cierto
no podía ser cierto es más me tocaba
decirles que se aguantaban tres meses se
les quitarían esos malestares de veras
creía que si alguien le kaymer un
medicamento y luego se lo toma tres
meses se le va a quitar
busque respuestas me inscribí en uno de
los programas académicos más exigentes
del país para convertirme en ginecólogo
me topé con los mejores maestros a nivel
nacional es más fui representante de
todos los residentes de mexico en
congresos internacionales
todos teníamos la misma información
y tal vez sea porque los anticonceptivos
hormonales son el tratamiento para todo
y actualmente el medicamento más vendido
y más recetado en el mundo generaron
generando una industria multimillonaria
a su lado
sin embargo
todos teníamos la misma información no
encontraba respuestas y en mi
desesperación
abrí la caja
ya dentro de la caja me encontré no solo
pastillas parches implantes anillos june
me encontré también un instructivo
generalmente tienen 20 páginas este
tiene 60 páginas de veras 60 páginas
para aprender a tomarte una pastilla
no era decir póngase la lengua tomó un
trago de agua
y listo
aquí lo impensable
por primera vez me di cuenta que mis
pacientes tenían razón que sus miedos
tenían fundamento que sus quejas eran
ciertas aquí de manera muy sutil
reconocían la relación que existía entre
estos medicamentos y el cáncer entre
estos medicamentos y la trombosis entre
estos medicamentos y la muerte deje de
consumirlos si tiene un dolor intenso en
el pecho que se le irradia al brazo
izquierdo dificultad para respirar
pérdida parcial o completa de la visión
imposibilidad para hablar
sólo les faltó poner deje de tomárselo
si ya está muerto
no conozco una mujer que después de
muerta se embaraza puede suspenderlo
un parteaguas en mi vida
por ahora tenía la información de que
estos medicamentos podían hacerle daño a
mis pacientes y por otro lado esto era
el tratamiento actual recomendado para
todo para lo que yo había estudiado que
hacer
qué harían ustedes dáselo a mis
pacientes dárselo a mi esposa pensar en
dárselo en mis hijas no podía no quería
me urgía a una opción me urgía una
respuesta y la respuesta la encontré
poniendo nuevamente a la mujer en su
ciclo en el centro de mi atención
descubrí que había otros muchos
científicos en el mundo que habían
estudiado a las mujeres y que habían
puesto y sentado las bases de la
fisiología y la bioquímica del
funcionamiento hormonal de las mujeres y
que estaba ahí publicado tal vez no muy
promovido pero desde hace 20 30 50 y
hasta 100 años en particular me encontré
con un médico en eeuu en omaha nebraska
en la universidad de creighton él había
desarrollado un sistema con este mismo
nombre y él había integrado todo este
conocimiento de la fisiología las
hormonas y la evolución del ciclo de las
mujeres y había encontrado que todos
estos cambios tenían una manifestación
externa y que las mujeres y sus parejas
podían reconocerlos
fácilmente y graficar los de tal forma
que las mujeres sus parejas podían
entender saber y predecir cuándo estaban
fértiles y cuando no estaban fértiles a
lo largo de su ciclo out
obsequiándole es una super información
para tener toda la libertad del mundo
este sistema había crecido como una
nueva opción para las mujeres que
querían vivir su sexualidad libremente y
poco a poco se ha ido convirtiendo en la
piedra angular de la nanotecnología una
nueva forma de ejercer la ginecología
que rescata los principios fundamentales
de la ciencia y les incorpora toda la
tecnología que hay hasta este momento y
lo pone al servicio de las mujeres ya
nosotros sus médicos nos permite
diagnosticar las causas y tratar
específicamente porque la mujer plasma y
toda la evolución y todos los cambios
hormonales normales y anormales de su
ciclo y nos permite identificar precisar
y tratar cosas tan fáciles como la
depresión postparto el síndrome
premenstrual quistes en los ovarios
hasta cosas tan complejas como la
infertilidad o las mujeres que tienen
abortos de manera repetida
había encontrado por fin una nueva forma
de ejercer mi profesión viendo a mis
pacientes a los ojos y sabiendo que no
les hacía daño en todo este proceso tuve
la fortuna el honor y el gusto de
encontrarme con otros mexicanos con los
que hemos ido haciendo equipo en
particular con dos que se han que eran
mis compañeros en la especialidad que
tuvieron la misma inquietud que yo que
nos fuimos juntos a estudiar que se han
vuelto mis amigos mis socios casi mis
hermanos y que juntos decidimos hacer la
primera clínica en méxico y
latinoamérica que ofrece esta nueva
opción de tratamiento de manera integral
a todas las mujeres
yo me enamoré de esta forma de hacer
ginecología me apasionó y esta nueva
forma fíjense uno es segura es decir no
tiene efectos secundarios nocivos ni
peligrosos para la salud de nadie
2 es para todas
se ha utilizado en condiciones como en
calcuta en nigeria con los incas en perú
en mujeres con ciclos regulares y
regulares en periodo de lactancia en
cualquier momento de su vida
reproductiva 3
es eficiente es efectiva 99.6 por ciento
de efectividad anticonceptiva comparable
con cualquier otro método y me queda
claro que esta estrategia no pretende
erradicar el embarazo en adolescentes no
pretende erradicar las infecciones de
transmisión sexual no pretende erradicar
el calentamiento global ni mucho menos
el terrorismo pero si pretende
ofrecerles a ustedes las mujeres una
nueva opción de cuidado personal que les
ofrece total libertad
incluso libre de hormonas
y 4 es saludable como les expliqué hace
rato nos permite a nosotros sus médicos
reconocer y tratar con precisión
prácticamente cualquier condición de su
ciclo en fin termino no quiero terminar
antes de hacer un llamado especial a
nuestras instituciones ya nuestras
autoridades a que investiguen a que
desarrollen a que impulsen y generen
nuevas formas de cuidado a nuestras
mujeres
que no les hagan daño
a mis colegas
a los científicos a los médicos
ginecólogos y de cualquier otra
especialidad a que no nos cansemos de
aprender a que volvamos a pensar el
motivo por el que somos nuestros
pacientes y los volvamos a poner en el
centro de nuestra atención y de todo
nuestro esfuerzo a ustedes los hombres a
la sociedad en general a que apoyen a
sus mujeres a vivir libres
sobre todo a ustedes a las mujeres todas
las que me ven para que se atrevan a ser
libres a vivir libres de hormonas para
que rompan este muro
para que aprendan a escuchar el idioma
en el que les habla su cuerpo y lo
comprendan
porque ustedes son lo mejor que nos ha
pasado y no queremos que se nos sigan
muriendo muchas gracias
[Música]